what do you want Rani Ora to look and  feel like in 10 20 or 30 years time  people love to live here and we're  growing rapidly by 2048 more than 30,000  people will call run Yura home we're now  planning for the town's  ongoing growth and success and we want  your ideas as new neighborhoods emerge  we need to think about building the  right type of housing developing new  parks and green spaces providing areas  for shops and community facilities and  time it all together with great options  for driving walking cycling and public  transport we also need to make sure the  run you are a town centre continues to  develop successfully and has room to  expand how do we build on our centre to  create a vibrant attractive place where  people enjoy living working and spending  their free time help us shape run  Norah's future they tell us what you  want to see happen tell us your ideas at  Waimakariri  but govt tea got in said hua / run your  [Music]